you know nobody wants to go see a movie
where the protagonist only has great
things happen to them and then the movie
ends
you want to see the whole trajectory you
want to see the
low moment you want to see the rock
bottom you want to see the self-doubt
you want to see the redemption
and so we're all kind of in our own
version of that hero's journey
and so knowing you can't go wrong that's
the great news about it right whatever
your belief is about what i'm saying or
about what
you've read somewhere that you've
dismissed you can't go wrong that's
a part of the story and that's what's so
great about it you know
whether it's a traffic jam or um someone
sideswipes your car
someone you know gets sick like that's a
part of your story
and all i'm saying is if you can be
open to the fact that there's some
opportunity there
whatever it is then it will
gift you with some insight that you
would not have had otherwise that could
help you bring about the things that you
feel are you're being blocked from
because if you're in that situation
where you're thinking okay i'm i'm
i don't have any time to think or space
to think about any of these kinds of
really highfalutin
you know self-actualization concepts
then it's it's usually
you you see your job or you see your
family situation as the obstacle and as
as our friend ryan holiday says you know
the obstacle is the way
but you have to you have to be open to
that as a possibility
so i just want to help people look at
that differently
right the other the other big stumbling
block and you've spoken about this quite
a bit
is is the inner critic you know that
that keeps people from even getting out
of the gate or
or even contemplating the possibility
that change is available yeah
and look i don't want to sugarcoat any
of this that that's a really that's a
real thing your inner critic is a real
thing
and what i'm doing is i'm showing you
that it didn't come out of nowhere like
their inner critic
develops and gets cultivated over many
many years in many instances of
reinforcing that belief
and so in order to really overcome it
properly
we have to do the opposite we have to
reinforce
a different type of belief and if we
have enough empirical evidence enough
experience for ourselves that you know
there's some light at the end of this
tunnel
then if we keep moving in that direction
then eventually we will be able to
contend with the
the fear and the inner critic and all
those other things that are kind of
stopping us from accessing
our our full potential and so i just i
you know that's the whole
idea of these stories is just to kind of
chip away
at the critic and all those other inner
voices that i
we all have inside of us like i have
them you have them
whoever's listening to this has them the
only difference in someone who
seems to be on their path and someone
who feels like lost
is that it's not that that person is
less busy or less
fearful or any of those things it's just
that that person has
usually challenged those
small moments where the inner voice
seems
to be driving the agenda and they've
experimented with
a different choice long enough
and held on the in there long enough for
some new
insight to take shape sure and that
requires
awareness plus courage but developing
those
always goes back to getting quiet right
there's no end run
around this inner work because if you're
not
consciously aware of how you're
operating in the world
and responding to the signals and the
stimuli that are getting thrown at you
then you're incapable of seeing the
broader patterns that continue to play
out in your life
that then you know prevents you from
being able to create that new narrative
to understand when it's the critic
that's creeping up
or the fear response so that you can
make a conscious choice to
behave in contradiction to that yeah and
i would give your audience credit i'm
sure
no one listen i mean you know there are
very few people listening to this
particular podcast
who aren't at least a little bit open to
to that that different sort of of path
just from your own personal story you
know and transformation
and so yeah it starts with awareness and
and that's that's
all i want to do is help people become
aware i don't have
i don't have everyone's you know one
there's no one-size-fits-all solution to
any of it
[Music]
[Music]
you